bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 5 janvier voici les
titres de l'actualité locale
alors que la vaccination contre le colis
de 19 a débuté en france et devraient
s'intensifier d'après le gouvernement
une première campagne est déployé à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cet après midi
les résidents volontaires de l'ehpad de
plaisir se sont vu administrer une dose
du vaccin fader nous étions sur place il
ya deux mois le centre des mortemets à
versailles a dû se réorganiser en
quelques jours le site d'hébergement
d'urgence a accueilli cent douze
migrants supplémentaires
ces personnes avaient été évacuées du
camp de saint-denis démanteler le 17
novembre dernier
et puis c'est un phénomène qui a touché
les yvelines la vague de mutilation de
chevaux à laisse un traumatisme dans le
monde équin pour l'endiguer la filière
s'est associé à l'état et à la
gendarmerie nationale dans un protocole
de prévention
une première initiative du genre en
france dont la convention a été signée
récemment à saint nom la bretèche invité
tout à l'heure également de cette
édition martin de la barre et carole
carole de galles de la croix rouge
française des yvelines pour parler et
des actions de l'association notamment
cette période de crise sanitaire
après les critiques le gouvernement
réagit le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand a annoncé ce matin que la
stratégie vaccinale allait être
amplifiées accélérer et simplifier
parmi les annonces à retenir tous les
français de plus de 75 ans pourront être
vaccinés avant la fin janvier
la vaccination est élargi aux pompiers
aide à domicile de plus de 50 ans les
français qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner pourront se signaler en
attendant la campagne se poursuit dans
les ehpad de france et cet après-midi et
des premières doses ont été administrées
à plaisir sur place bixente mais rien
senti steban et patrick jacques de
dixmude l'unité de soins longue durée du
centre hospitalier de plaisir a
accueilli ce mardi 5 décembre une
campagne de vaccination la première sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
parmi les résidents ils étaient dix
volontaires à se faire administrer le
vaccin contre la copie 19 87 me pousse à
des choses que qui soit juste de ces
vaccins faut profiter
c'était c'était peut-être cet après-midi
on démarre on a donc là qu signer cinq
résidants de l'unité de soins de longue
durée et juste avant cinq résidants de
l'ehpad les résidents du effectuée au
préalable un bilan de santé
une précaution pour savoir si tout
allait bien bien entendu ce vaccin
n'était pas une obligation
des consultations avec les personnes et
leurs familles avait été réalisée au
préalable
c'était une urgence et on nous a fait
cette proposition puisque on a eu la
chance je dirais d'être choisi parmi les
ai pas de prioritaire c'est la seconde
opération dans le département après
celle de l'ehpad mon repos de
sartrouville le 31 décembre dernier
on imagine bien que voilà une fois passé
peut-être les premiers jours des
premières semaines certaines personnes
réticentes viendront vers la vaccination
en tout cas on va faire ce travail de
pédagogie qui nous semble essentiel
après on restera respectueux voilà des
choix individuels et j'irai qu'on fera
voilà on fera les comptes à la fin
un établissement de plus parmi les 700
programmés par la rs ile de france d'ici
à la fin du mois de janvier pour saint
quentin en yvelines
aucune autre cession n'est prévue pour
le moment une campagne qui se poursuit
dans un contexte de léger rebond de
l'épidémie dans les yvelines après les
fêtes
regardez le taux d'incidence nombre de
personnes contaminées pour 100000
habitants a augmenté en une semaine plus
20 même tendance du côté du taux de
tests positifs les chiffres hospitaliers
sont eux à deux vitesses baisse du
nombre d'hospitalisations mais dans le
même temps davantage de patients placés
en réanimation est depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1088 personnes sont
décédées du colis de 19 dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois mais je vous le
disais dans les titres le centre d
mortemer à versailles a accueilli cent
douze migrants supplémentaires en fin
d'année l'association cité à caritas a
pris en charge le site d'hébergement
pour répondre à l'évacuation du camp de
saint denis c'était le 17 novembre
dernier au total aux mortemets près de
150 personnes sont accompagnés un
reportage de justin brasier après le
démantèlement du camp de saint denis le
17 novembre dernier une partie des
migrants a été accueilli au centre des
mortes mais de versailles l'association
cité caritas et la société ic i sécurité
ont pris en main le centre
le dispositif a été mis en place en cinq
jours seulement
ici c'était la croix rouge qui était
avant
et ils sont partis donc le 12 ils ont
quitté les lieux
on a récupéré un site qu'on a repris de
zéro et en cinq jours on a on va essayer
de faire le maximum pour m pour tout
mettre en place pour accueillir les
migrants qui arrivent et le 17 c'était
un petit peu innovant comme façon de
faire on a mobilisé tout le monde y
compris un petit groupe de personnes
hébergées tibétaine qui nous a aidé à
faire le nettoyage a monté les lie près
de 150 personnes sont accueillies sur
place dont 112 ont été prises en charge
suite à l'évacuation du camp de saint
denis
on a un public essentiellement afghans
avec diverses situations administratives
il y en a qui sont pas loin du statut de
réfugié donc de petits viennent
d'arriver pour lesquels il faut tout
faire et puis une population jeune en
2007 j'ai rentré de paris
moi je dois quand même le premier un an
a pris deux ans maintenant j'attends
dépôt de documents et de séjour gratton
sur place et les migrants sont nourris
logés et accompagné au programme
démarches administratives et cours de
français le mardi et le jeudi
en matinée on a des bénévoles du secours
catholique qui viennent et qui est de
l'est
migrants qui veulent apprendre le
français c'était très très demandeur à
leur arrivée une première étape pour le
centre d'hébergement d'urgence des
mortes mais qui se veut durable
objectif réorienter les migrants vers
d'autres centres adaptés j'accueille à
présent deux invités qui sont avec moi
en visioconférence martin de la barre et
carole le gall bonsoir martin de la
barre vous êtes la directrice
territoriale yvin pour la croix rouge
française on va parler
la présidente j'ai pu j'ai dit la
directrice vous êtes la présidente
pardon de la direction territoire
délégation territoriale de la croix
rouge française dans les illinois y
arriver mais d'abord avant de parler
avec vous de l'engagement de
l'association dans cette crise sanitaire
quelques questions avec vous qu'un rôle
de galles pour faire suite à notre
dernier reportage sur l'accueil des
migrants je précise que vous êtes la
directrice du pôle lutte contre les
exclusions pour la croix-rouge des
yvelines la croixrouge ça fait partie de
ces missions est mobilisé dans
l'accompagnement des personnes migrantes
quels accompagnements justement leur
apportez vous alors sur le département
des yvelines
on a quatre établissements qui
permettent l'accueil des personnes en
situation des rations et en demande
d'asile en cours de procédure de demande
d'asile
on héberge 630 personnes sur quatre
établissements avec donc la volonté
d'accompagner ces personnes dans tous
leurs processus de demande d'asile
tout ce qui est autour aussi de
l'ouverture des droits tout ce qui est
autour de l'accompagnement post
procédure c'est le statut est obtenue
pour ceux qui on tienne le statut de
réfugié donc tout un travail
d'accompagnement social un travail aussi
de découverte de l'environnement dans
lequel on retrouve sur les yvelines et
puis de projets personnalisés en lien
avec les attentes aussi des personnes
qu'on héberge nous on héberge
essentiellement des hommes et des femmes
on n'a pas de famille on vous lisiez un
accompagnement pendant leurs démarches
administratives mais aussi après parce
que l'idée c'est aussi de favoriser leur
insertion à ces personnes absolument
absolument oui tout à fait une fois que
les statuettes obtenu l'objectif est
vraiment travailler avec eux dans
l'insertion là
la connaissance de notre pays aussi
pourquoi parce que c'est pour certains
des primo arrivants
et puis la connaissance de la langue
avec tout projet qui va derrière qui est
peut-être projet professionnel en
premier lieu en date et non vous en avez
peut-être un peu parlé déjà mais ce
qu'il ya des actions particulières sur
sur département des yvelines alors sur
le département des yvelines
on est très en phase avec les
associations justement bah pourquoi pas
aussi celle que qu'accompagne martin ou
d'autres aussi on n'est pas exclusif à
la part aux gens travaillent avec
d'autres associations également pour ce
qui est justement de l'apprentissage de
la langue
on a beaucoup de bénévoles aussi qui
viennent nous soutenir dans ses actions
à accompagner ben voilà tous les
accompagnements spécifique nous au sein
des établissements vraiment orienté sur
la procédure d'asile et ensuite à leur
malaise se fait avec les partenaires
locaux avec des centres d'hébergement
d'urgence dans les parlements
alors nous on est sur deux centres
d'hébergement d'urgence pour le migrant
et 2 du dha dans le jargon un peu
d'établissements sociaux cds hébergement
d'urgence pour demandeurs d'asile ou là
on est vraiment focalisé sur la mission
d'accompagnement des migrants parmi tant
d'autres la croix rouge l'association
martine de la barre traverse on imagine
bien une période particulière avec
l'épidémie de e.coli 19 malgré tout ça
c'est une mission importante de la croix
rouge c'est l'action sociale est ce
qu'elle est plus difficile à assumer
quand même cette action au vu du
contexte
alors oui elle et elle est en tous les
cas elle est heureusement très selon le
la crise en fonction de la crise c'est à
dire que nous nous deux missions
principales c'est vraiment d'accompagner
les personnes les plus fragilisées par
cette crise depuis de lutter contre l'
isolement social ça c'est vraiment très
important et donc on a recentré nos
activités ont des grosses grosses
associations et commet une grosse
association c'est se mettre en ordre de
marche très rapidement parce que
l'urgence on s'est préparé à ça et on
essaye de le faire vite
donc dès le mois de mars on s'est mis en
ordre de marche pour pouvoir continuer
l'émission alimentaire l'accompagnement
alimentaire la domiciliation postale
ça c'était très important et surtout
pour lutter contre l' isolement social
on a mis en place ce qu'on appelle croix
rouge vous vous avez bien entendu parler
je porte ce qu'on connaissait une
plateforme téléphonique où les gens
pouvaient appeler peuvent encore appelé
on a gâché leur nourriture et leur
apporter directement chez eux vers le
numéro de téléphone va s'afficher c'est
peut-être déjà si c'est dans cet
entretien pour rire
donc ça c'est une action qui continue
cette action-là excentré à développer
parce que à l'heure actuelle les gens se
sont organisés entre voisins avec les
mairies etc et donc on a moins besoin de
cela
en revanche on a mis en place qu'on
appelle à l'eau comment ça va c'est à
dire qu'on a dans la continuité des gens
qui nous appelaient on continue à les
appeler encore tout le temps
régulièrement aux bénévoles les appels
de façon à écouter qu'ils puissent
parler parce que l' isolement
c'est vraiment difficile à l'heure
actuelle à planter c'est vraiment ça que
les gens les gens sont très isolés
on le ressent vraiment très fort la
réaction des maraudes aussi continue ou
l'imaginent ah non
les maraudes continue sur le territoire
des éléments pour toujours pour
isolement avec rigueur et nous salariés
puisque la croix-rouge et samu social
car elle est donc la directrice
également du samu social et donc nos
maraudes on les a même renforcé
évidemment on est âgé alors ça on en a
fait tous les jours et on les fait bien
sûr encore ça c'est très important
et puis il faut savoir aussi qu'on a
beaucoup on est venus en renfort
énormément au samu 70 on est vieux c'est
vrai que c'est le sait le secourisme est
également l'urgence on en avait parlé
d'ailleurs deux dans le premier
confinement il ya il ya eu un renfort
auprès du samu ça se poursuit du coup
alors à l'heure actuelle le samu tant
mieux avaient moins besoin de nous parce
que la demande était moins important
dire qu'il ya moins de malades qui
arrivait et puis donc ça tant mieux
j'espère qu'on n'aura pas besoin de nous
finalement je fais le souhait que on est
plus maison nous pour l'instant des
moins présent et dans tout ça on ne le
répète jamais assez l'importance des
bénévoles
rien ne se ferait sans ses bénévoles
pour vous dire nous avons aidé le seul
chiffre que je vais vous donner ces
quarante deux mille personnes dans les
yvelines dans cette année c'est cool et
on a mobilisé dix mille bénévoles de
notre association
vraiment voilà on a été très présents je
souhaite que vous parlez des vaccins
mais vraiment j'espère que les vaccins
voir et les vite vite vite et que nous
sortions de cette crise vraiment
terrible et qu'il isole les personnes
savoir mobilisation des bénévoles
anciens que la croix rouge fonctionne on
l'a dit grâce à ses moyens humains
on parle également au moment des
journées nationales de la croix rouge de
des besoins en dons est ce que il ya
besoin encore de dons pour aussi financé
financer les actions de la croix rouge
on a toujours besoin de dons demandé à
une association le jour où elle aura
plus besoin de dons fait que on notera
plus rien donc oui oui vous pouvez
évidemment continuer à donner
nous savons nous feront bon usage des
dons que nous avons vous le savez on a
besoin de vous on a besoin de bénévoles
en a besoin d'argent on a besoin de tout
évidemment évidemment et je j'ajoute que
malheureusement les formations grand
public où on était un peu stoppé mais
nous avons dit nous former des gens à la
faune gestes barrière est à la fois à
l'initiation à l'affinement des risques
très important de savoir comment se
prendre en charge quand il y a comme ça
une catastrophe il une ni c'est
très important continue à se former là
dessus la croix rouge est toujours
présent sur ce terrain
merci martin de la barre et merci à
carole le gall d'avoir été avec nous un
dernier mot d'ailleurs je parlais de
dons et un dernier mot sur la
croix-rouge l'unité locale de saint
quentin en yvelines fait un appel aux
dons on en parlait de ses dons il ya un
instant alors pour l'unité locale elle a
besoin de changer son ambulance pour se
mettre aux normes actuelles ambulance
airs ou au poste de secours pour des
manifestations accueillant un public
important ou lors d'événements
particuliers pour chaque don supérieur à
50 euros une initiation aux premiers
secours sera offerte un tout
les informations et aussi pour faire des
dons sur le lien qui s'affiche en bas
d'écran dans le reste de l'actualité
cette disparition on l'a appris hier le
décès de jean gombert ancien maire de
bois d'arcy il est décédé vendredi
dernier à angers il a été donc le maire
de la commune de boire de bois d'arcy
pendant un seul mandat entre 1989 et
1995 avant que la commune ne basculent à
gauche pendant 19 ans dans un post sur
les réseaux sociaux le député des
yvelines philippe benassaya ancien maire
de bois d'arcy
elle lui a rendu hommage à jean gombert
lui avait donné dit il de précieux
conseils avant sa première élection à la
mairie en 2014
une convention signée entre la
préfecture des yvelines la gendarmerie
et la filière équestre elle a été signée
la semaine dernière ah ça non à botrel à
saint-nom-la-bretèche avec un objectif
mettre en place un nouveau protocole
protocole devait arriver de protection
de protection un protocole de protection
des équidés les équidés qui ont été
victimes d'une large vague de mutilation
à ces derniers mois elle et précision
dans ce sujet d'eléonore sinoquet et
nicolas landry vigilance et à qui des
c'est le nom de la convention qui a été
signée mercredi 30 décembre dans les
écuries du poste à cheval de saint nom
la bretèche entre le monde équestre
l'état et la gendarmerie
objectif assurer la protection des
chevaux après la vague de mutilation
d'équidés de ces derniers mois
c'est une première nationale et ce qui
est très intéressant ce devoir là ton
job
la conjugaison des efforts de tous le
secteur privé des centres équestres des
éleveurs des militaires avec la
gendarmerie nationales la gendarmerie la
garde républicaine
donc c'est fini une innovation mais ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est la conjugaison
de nos efforts pour protéger les équidés
dans le département cette convention
vise à créer un réseau départemental des
changes et de solidarité entre forces de
l'ordre et monde équestre
pour ce faire 15 référent et quittant
seront répartis sur le territoire
i'm all ce sera emma bataillon le rôle
en fait c'est de faire le contact entre
les différents acteurs donc notamment
gendarmerie pour faire remonter
l'information le plus vite possible et
et agir en cas de en cas d'événement ce
que l'on ne cède pas bien sûr les
yvelines n'ont pas été choisies au
hasard pour être le premier territoire a
signé ce nouveau protocole de protection
quinze mille chevaux et plus de 800
propriétaires c'est le premier
département équestre d'île de france et
il comporte aussi deux unités de
gendarmes à cheval
l'émission de 7 de ces deux unités sont
assez classique ça nous permet encore
une fois donc de faire du contact du
renseignement avec la population et puis
évidemment donc d'avoir des relations
très particulières avec le monde du
cheval d'une manière globale donc les
centres équestres les haras et puis
naturellement on a donc au travers ces
deux unités là donc une action très
résolus et offensive sur tout ce qui est
atteinte à l'environnement d'une manière
générale c'est beaucoup plus simple
parce que les gens viennent beaucoup
plus nous voir et il nous donne beaucoup
de renseignements qui ne n'aurais pas
forcément donné un véhicule et en armure
et en plus des 15 référent et quittant
un guide va aussi être diffusé et des
panonceaux affiché pour aller encore
plus loin dans la sécurité la préfecture
des yvelines qui a dévoilé il ya
quelques jours cette nouvelle dix
petites ou moyennes communes vont
bénéficier d'un programme son nom petite
ville de demain dans les yvelines ce
programme est intégrée dans le plan de
relance est une enveloppe de 6 milliards
2,3 milliards d'euros sur six ans pour
permettre le développement des communes
de moins de vingt mille habitants parmi
elles jouèrent pouchard train son maire
réagit au micro d'eléonore s'est moqué
[Musique]
beaucoup un sur sept
sur ce stand de l'état puisque nous
avons dans notre projet beaucoup d'idées
pour améliorer le vivre ensemble de la
commune pour l'utiliser centre-ville
pour essayer de rénover nos
infrastructures existantes
[Musique]
il avait précisé aujourd'hui d'après ce
que l'on m'a dit c'est que la première
étape dans son coin de l'oeil d'un
directeur de projet pour nous aider à
faire un plan de territoire qu'est le
premier projet c'est ce que j'appelle à
un clan guide où l'idée c'est de nous
associer à un architecte assez connus
qui s'appelle alexandre chemetoff dont
il nous a proposé de nous aider pendant
les pros - qui viennent à faire un
travail de réflexion de visualisation de
notre année à 15 ou 20 ans
ça c'est un élément essentiel c'est un
travail qui va nous permettre son équipe
d'adjoints en équipe municipale et lui
est bien de décliner les projets que
nous aurons un point global stic a
réalisé dans ce mandat le maire donc de
jouars-pontchartrain joueurs
pontchartrain qui fait partie à des dix
petits touma une commune qui vont
bénéficier je vous le rappelle de ce
programme petite ville de demain dans
les yvelines
toute cette semaine tv 60,18 vous
propose de revivre les événements qui
ont fait 2020 dans le département une
année qui a vu bien sûr l'émergence de
la crise sanitaire du coronavirus ce
soir retour d'avril à juin 2020 avec
nicolas d'andré
le silence dans les rues se fait
toujours entendre au mois d'avril
mais si les corps des yvelinois sont
confinés leurs esprits restent ouverts
l'astronaute français jean françois
clervoy habitué au confinement lors de
ses voyages dans l'espace ne dit pas le
contraire dans ces conseils donnés pour
vivre cette épreuve c'est très important
d'être de s'astreindre à peu à se donner
à la planning
si on attend que quelqu'un me dise quoi
faire on peut facilement se retrouver à
devenir oisiveté c'est malsain avec les
esprits et les coeurs sont aussi tournés
vers les autres des élans de solidarité
spontanée émergent
ce jeune runner a fait un marathon dans
son jardin une performance dans le cadre
d'un mécénat autour de la chirurgie
cardiaque des actions pour soutenir les
soignants ce garagiste propose des prix
réduits pour réparer les véhicules des
soignants le chef étoilé de la table du
11 jean baptiste lavergne mort adjani a
cuisiné pour le personnel hospitalier
une solidarité pouvant aller au bout de
la vie le docteur jacques fribourg
médecin urgentiste retraités de
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien de
trappes est décédée à cause du coc vite
19 il était sorti de sa retraite pour
aider le personnel soignant de
l'établissement à affronter la crise
sanitaire
chaque ces symboles pour nous l'été il
est unique dans son hôpital dans son
établissement depuis un mois s'est battu
comme un diable pour survivre et il
décède chez nous aussi un sentiment
beaucoup de tristesse s'est énormément
tristesse puis l'espoir vient le 13
avril 2020 de l'elysée le confinement le
plus strict doit encore se poursuivre
jusqu'au lundi 11 mai
le déconfinement sera progressif par
territoire tous les commerces dits non
essentiels pourront rouvrir
tout comme les crèches et les écoles
maternelles et primaires
et quand le 11 mai est arrivée alors moi
je veux pas du tout sorti et c'est un
petit peu bizarre on se regarde tous là
un peu peur mais après faut sortir du
jeu rendez vous chez le coiffeur là dans
dix minutes
donc voila c'était la première la
première chose à faire ce matin les
coiffeurs ont fait le plein les golfeurs
ont pu revenir sur les greens et les
magasins des centres commerciaux ont
relevé leurs rideaux avec une
organisation particulière pour respecter
les règles sanitaires
puis le 2 juin c'est au tour des
enseignements qui ont repris dans les
collèges et les lycées
les restaurateurs ont pu remettre les
couverts et reprendre du service
le serveur on démasque pour le servir
les clients achètent et marées on peut
avoir des masques à table elle a perdu
par contre l'iran dans l'établissement
ils mettront des masques pour aller aux
toilettes on va éviter qu'ils viennent
payer à la caisse à table le
déconfinement concerne aussi les élus
politiques ils ont pu de nouveau se
réunir en assemblée
c'est le cas de l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvin hauts-de-seine
qui a pu élire georges siffredi à la
présidence de l'organisation
suite à la disparition de patrick
devedjian après un premier tour au mois
de mars le second tour des élections
municipales de 2020 a été organisée le
28 juin
suite à ce scrutin quatre nouveaux
maires ont été élus à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aux
clayes-sous-bois philippe guiguen
devient le nouvel édile de la commune à
villepreux le candidat modem jean
baptiste à mo'nique a remporté les
suffrages les trappistes ont voté
majoritairement pour le candidat de la
gauche aly rabais enfin la verrière a
basculé à droite avec la victoire de
nicolas dainville une commune sous
pavillon communiste depuis 1977
et puis avant de vous laisser météo
france a placé les yvelines et
l'ile-de-france en vigilance jaune à la
neige et au verglas quelques flocons
pourraient tomber cette semaine à saint
quentin en yvelines d'ailleurs
l'agglomération propose un service d'
alerte par sms lorsque des opérations de
salage ou de déneigement sont déclenchés
ce service est gratuit il suffit de vous
inscrire sur le portail peps
une démarche a réitéré chaque année car
les numéros de téléphones ne sont pas
conservées par l'agglomération d'un
univers à l'autre
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité on se retrouve dès
demain mercredi pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]